We all love the company of our favorite people!
Similarly, Hydrocarbon chains are also fond
of other molecules.
They get bonded
so strongly that the properties of the compound
change depending on the
molecules attached.
And what are these group of molecules referred
to as?
They
are called as the Functional Groups, that’s
right!
Let us get to know about them.
Beginning with the definition first!
How do we define them?
In simple words,
these are the group of atoms that give characteristic
properties to the compounds
in which they are present.
Yes!
Their presence is quite influential!
If they’re a part
of a compound, the entire compound takes its
properties!
Have we come across any of the functional
groups ever?
Yes!
We’ve heard many
names like Alcohols, Phenols, Ethers and so
on!
Animators: Show all the below ones with structures:
Look at the structures carefully!
What do you notice?
It helps us understand that they have atoms
which can form at least one bond
with any other atom.
Yes at least one atom in the complete group
is ready for
bond formation.
That is the reason why they can easily bond
with any other atom and become a
part of any compound easily.
Let’s understand this in a simple way.
Say we focus on this structure of Alcohol.
This functional group has one oxygen
atom and one hydrogen atom.
That means a hydroxyl unit is what makes up
the
alcoholic group.
Can you notice that we have drawn a line before
oxygen here?
What does this
indicate?
Well, it indicates that the group is available
for bond formation!
So
there can be any other atom bonded to the
oxygen atom of this hydroxyl unit!
So if we take any carbon chain, say something
like this, then we can attach the
alcoholic functional group at the carbon atom
which is available for bond
formation.
And the new compound gets formed in this way!
Similarly, talking about the functional group
CARBOXYLIC ACID, its structure is
somewhat like this!
Represented as dash followed by COOH, the
group contains one carbon atom!
Out of the 4 bonds that it can form, 3 are
already formed.
As we can see here,
one oxygen atom is attached to the carbon
atom with a DOUBLE BOND while
another single bond is with a hydroxyl group.
This is how we get COOH as our
carboxyl group.
Now from from where will this group be attached
to the hydrocarbon chain?
Yes!
From the carbon atom!
And why is that?
We know that the valency of carbon is
FOUR.
Three bonds in the functional group have got
formed leaving behind just
one.
That is why the line is drawn before Carbon
atom which indicates that the
group can be attached from here!
Where do you think this group will be attached?
It can be attached to an Alkyl
group!
Wait…what do we mean by an alkyl group?
We’ve seen what Alkanes, alkenes and alkynes
are!
Single bonds: Alkanes!
At
least one doube bond: Alkenes.
And at least one triple bond: Alkynes!
So what is
an alkyl group then?
Let’s take an example of ethane to understand
this!
We can see that each carbon atom here has
its valencies completely fulfiled.
Four
and four!
However, if we remove even one hydrogen atom,
then the group becomes
capable of forming bonds with other compounds.
Like in this case it can bond
with a functional group from this point!
This thing that you see here is an ALKYL
group.
It is just derived from an alkane by removing
on of its hydrogen atoms!
That’s all.
Here it has been derived from ethane!
Hence it’s called an ETHYL group!
Similarly, if we remove one hydrogen atom
from Methane, it will be called a
METHYL group!
Alkyl groups are usually represented with
the letter “R” written in
upper case.
This was a general overview of what alkyl
groups are!
But the main topic of this video was functional
groups.
They’re a group of atoms
that give characteristic properties to the
compounds in which they are present.
The entire compound takes its properties!
Let us have a look at a few more
interesting examples of functional groups
in the next video!